Thank you,
President, Mr.
Bolaños,
how far the government IS going to go
to free the socialists from jail
implicated in corruption cases.
Nothing. Whenever you want,
Mr. Bolaños,
it is you who answers me on this occasion.
However,
I am grateful that you have not commented.
congratulating himself,
as he did a few days ago at a press conference.
But be careful,
because the tyrant's apprentices do not tolerate the existence of
doubles as narcissistic as he is.
You have absolutely everything.
They have assaulted the institutions,
They have emptied the Constitution,
They have profited in the middle of 1 pandemic and have designed
laws tailored to the needs of rapists and coup perpetrators.
They have left nothing behind,
from parliamentary forms to
judicial independence.
It has never been
Spain governed by the most excellent without excellence
and more lordships without lordship.
No matter how many titles those armchairs give them.
They will never have the honorability of the Spanish People,
whom you humiliate every day with your cockiness
and their dark practices.
They are very disturbing
all the coincidences of the processes
that affect
to the socialist party.
Let's make 1 review,
7 corruption cases that commit the PSOE are going to be
archived due to errors
during the process.
There are 3 clear pieces of the cause of beings.
and another fraud case
of training courses.
The voucher case has also been closed.
that affected more than
of 25 socialists.
And the same with the isophoton case of The 40 investigated,
37 senior members of the Socialist Board,
are not the only causes,
if not ask the former director of the Civil Guard,
another fortunate one.
The same will happen with the President's wife.
Miscarriages of justice multiply,
cases are shelved and socialists are corrupt
smile.
And if they are still condemned,
you pardon them,
because to drink and pardon is the slogan of lineage.
to which you belong,
that of 1 political caste
privileged that believes itself to be above the law,
Tito Verni's cell phones
missing from the police safe,
thes between the interior and goldo's company
eliminated.
Nothing New in 1 government burying 1 scandal
with the following,
where ministers leak data from individuals
to cover up their own corruption.
You said the other day
that there was nothing more unpatriotic than to disappoint
to. Yes,
there is.
Using the money paid by all Spaniards
to pay criminals.
Now that's unpatriotic,
Mr. Minister.
It is not luck,
it is 1 political party
yours,
making USE of the state through 1 extortion system
perfect that now only
they envy mafias